what's the deal with airplane Peanuts
comic Shane Gillis out at SNL or if
after just a few days amid a firestorm
of criticism I was on a train going to
the St and just getting cancelled in
between stops and then the next
stop then the next off I don't remember
saying that I didn't say that if you say
something like that you can't work in a
sketch show but like it's okay from what
he can work at a lumber yard yeah he's
certainly going to meet more Asians
there
right then on SNL that's a it's a joke
about how SNL's not hiring asent Jes
Christ now I'm in trouble we're not
running for office when is this going to
5 years after being brutally fired from
Saturday Night Live in one of the
wildest series of events ever heard
Shane Gillis will officially be making
his long debated return to SNL as the
host of the show later this month I went
into L Michael's office and I was
convinced I was getting fired cuz if
they didn't get me on that there's so
much more so much worse he's like if we
just get you to the first first episode
like people will see you're not a piece
of person Saturday Night Live hiring
Shane Gillis after asking him to
audition only then to turn around and
publicly fire him hours later after
uncovering a clip from Shane's podcast
that contained what they described as
offensive hurtful and unacceptable jokes
is a story that's been told many times
and most people are aware of by now but
the thought that Shane Gillis would one
day get so big on his own that he would
return to SNL as the host of the show
after being ruthlessly canceled on
online used to only be a hypothetical
pipe dream brought up by day one fans
who believe that Shane would eventually
reach this point but those same fans
would still debate if he should even
give SNL the satisfaction when that day
comes now that this dream has become a
reality 99% of the comedy world is EST
static for Shane as this is not only the
ultimate form of vindication after his
unjust termination but also because real
comedians hosting SNL is always a win
however there's still a small group of
dogs online who would have rather seen
Shane give SNL the ultimate middle
finger by rejecting this gig as a form
of Revenge and although that would have
made plenty of headlines the chance to
host Saturday Night Live is still
basically impossible to pass up not only
when you think about the class of fellow
comedians to ever receive this offer but
also considering the ability for a gig
like this to raise your public profile
even more and just because Shane
accepted this job does not mean revenge
of some kind is out of the question if I
ever get on SNL I will budw I'll be like
live from my mouth this [__] gun most
eyes will be on Shane's opening
monologue as fellow Comedians and fans
alike seem to be rooting for Shane
Gillis to double down on stage and
really expose SNL for not actually
having any morals or comedic values of
their own which was showcased when they
fired a comedian for an Asian joke while
also having zero Asian cast members in
their 45-year history confirming that
these corporations don't really care
about problematic comments until it
affects their bottom line This behavior
is not new when it comes to SNL as the
same thing happened when legendary
comedian nor McDonald was fired from his
role on the show and brought back to
host just one year later with a
Vengeance that resulted in comedy gold I
know how did I go in a year and a half
from being not funny enough to be even
allowed in the
building to being so funny that I'm now
hosting the show how did I suddenly get
so damn
funny then it occurred to me I haven't
gotten funnier the show has gotten
really
bad plenty of fans online have already
drawn a comparison between Norm's iconic
monologue and the opportunity Shane has
to follow in the footsteps of one of his
favorite Comics just reached out he sent
me some cool stuff about like funny will
win yeah that was the coolest [__] ever
yeah he was like there's a war right I
don't want to I don't want to spill the
beans on a nice thing but it was like
you guys had a private thing yeah it was
cool end supportive when going he spoke
like poetically it was awesome yeah and
it ended one of the messages ended with
like in a war for comedy I think the
ones with jokes will win I just like yo
that's fire nor McDonald is King aside
from the opening monologue and the story
coming full circle another reason to
actually watch SNL February 24th is
because this will likely be one of their
best episodes in a long time strictly
based on the fact that Shane Gillis is
Elite at sketch writing and acting
compared to the normal celebrity guests
featured on SNL getting to work with a
legitimate sketch comedian must be a
relief for their entire staff your
sketches that you're doing those are the
best comedy sketches that are on the
internet right now this will likely be
one of the only episodes of Saturday
Night Live that I'll consider watching
live this season Shane Gillis putting up
big viewership numbers could possibly
open the door to other massive comedians
that are outside the SNL bubble like
theovon or Tim Dylan and like we've seen
in this video whatever makes the most
money is what Saturday Night Live is
going to be doing from here on out which
probably means there are multiple more
Shane appearances to come another thing
that's probable to happen is a boatload
of inflammatory articles written before
and after Shane's episode that will
likely quote jokes as literal statements
and draw wild conclusions which is a
testament and a drawback to Shane
gillis's name being able to generate so
many clicks if you go back 15 years in
somebody's life someone should then go
back 15 years in your life and
then going off what Bill bur said In
that clip the guy who originally tweeted
the clip that got Shane Gillis fired is
named cth Simmons and he deleted 7,000
of his own tweets that same day which is
a lot of racist tweets guest spots from
last week The Joe Rogan Experience had
on Jeff Dy two bears one cave was Burton
Tom Tom and Burke Kil Tony was joined by
jannis poet and Harland Williams godf
freed was on we might be drunk Brad
Williams was on are you garbage ymh
spoke with Joe D roza Andrew Santino
went on soda Richard Jefferson was on
Chrissy chaos and Rob Riggle was a guest
on whisky Ginger no speaking of which I
saw a billboard last night at one of
those LED trucks uh of uh kids who have
been abducted and uh a few of them I
recognized a few of those guys yeah
really yeah some of the guys that I I
think because I'm a part of a kid
kidnapping you said LED truck I didn't
know what you meant oh yeah yeah yeah so
I was envisioning like a one of those
Escalades that have the glow underneath
no no no this wasn't a party bus in
Vegas that's what the first thing that
popped in my mind yeah but a few of the
kids I had seen cuz I'm part of a group
of people that kidnapped kids and it's
nice that they some of our top picks on
the board they finally getting the
billing that they this past weekend with
Theo Von talked with Tim Dylan lar Lee
Shan Gardini and Nate Marshall were all
on Matt and Shane secret podcast arri
shafir was on the way back podcast Tosh
talked with his car guy David Drake was
on ban with Jordan the bloxs podcast had
on David Kenner Lil howy was on
tigerbelly Steve Ren is ZZ went on you
know what dude bertcast talked with Doug
Williams first date talked to Esther
pitz and taste buds returned with their
first episode of the Year Tris skits
vers Wheat Thins it's uh there's good
energy so far in here it feels good it
feels right it feels like we could
probably scream at each other in here
and get away with it right yeah well
we're going to find out as far as new
standup comedy specials are either out
right now or coming out soon Jeff Dunham
I'm with cupid is out right now on
Comedy Central Kevin James has a new
special titled irregardless that's out
on Prime video and there's a few new
projects out on YouTube as well
including Nate Jackson's crowdwork joint
and Dez Bishop of all people and even
though I've done comedy a long time I've
actually hardly ever performed in the
United States before 2015 so for the
first time in my life I'm performing
here at the Comedy Cellar with a lot of
black Comics not a lot of diversity in
the Irish comedy scene here a lot of
black Comics love working with them and
every single one that I met told me that
as far as they are concerned Desmond
Bishop is a very black
name now I never knew I had a black name
I knew that Desmond Bishop was a
linebacker for the Green Bay Packers cuz
every time he [__] up about 12 years
ago my Twitter would light up with angry
people from Wisconsin being like you fat
[__] you should have blocked that guy
and I be like that's not me I'm a skinny
white guy that's Dez Bishop 55 if you
want to find him he's Dez Bishop
55 there's also more than a few specials
that are in the works right now that
will be coming out soon including Taylor
Tomlinson have it all which premieres
February 13th and Mike EPS ready to sell
out on February 20th aside from the huge
Shane Gillis SNL news he also just
signed a contract with Bud Light there's
already been about a million big-time
news stories related to The Comedy world
this year from Mark Norman's show
evacuation stunt to Joe Rogan's massive
new deal with Spotify and even the new
two bears vodka brand we're going to be
covering it all right here and if you're
trying to stay in the comedy Loop
there's never been a better time to
subscribe to joke world thank you so
much for watching this video and if you
don't have anything going on right now
after this feel free to check out our
end screen there's two more great video
choices for you right
there thanks for
watching joke
World
it and the world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out